to welcome everybody to a stream podcast
today's episode is sponsored by quip and
expressvpn today's guest is Bobby Lee
and kalila from tiger belly podcast they
are outside on the Gatsby
Bobby has got his trigger finger on the
ignition as we speak before the chaos
begins let me just say the Bobby Lee's
tour dates there's already chaos back
there Bobby Lee's tour dates you can
find Matt Bobby Lee live.com for more
information there Bobby Lee live.com so
without further ado Bobby and kalila
please enter yeah right now there we go
[Laughter]
we have insurance
[Music]
did you did you do that before we did it
or was that is that the practice run let
me ask you something you go through the
safety where am I going
hey okay babe are you okay I was crushed
[Laughter]
I think it's the best you are the first
guests to do it I was a nice that did it
oh really and they did it all the way
through I saw you go through when you
became a citizen I did really hard so
let me describe what happened yeah Bobby
hit when I mean first of all you did not
shy away from the excel yeah
but you you case yeah doorway you must
not not the door off you hit the door
way off look Danny see that have you
seen his car okay well I feel like well
I feel like you should have probably
taken a look at his car before allowing
him already are you okay I'm the reason
why that's very very tight I'm the
reason why it does hmm right because I
just don't know exactly why the rules
are out there when we're driving and so
why they exist you don't know because I
feel like if they if everyone just did
what I did on the road there would be no
sense to be chaos
no there'd be those arse in this traffic
I believe everyone drove the way I did
like that he knows yes maybe
can I see your victory so that you know
you get here for my lawyer from okay
what was I was literally trying on your
foot I know like we're in 911 on I know
you weren't there my friend Steve was
running as easy but I'm kidding
it was a lot like nine yeah that's what
I felt like yeah because my leg was like
pinned yeah
right I was waiting for you
you're the fireman did you get hurt no
I'm fine oh my god yeah thank you guys
okay that was a hell of an entrance but
at any rate I missed you guys so much
thanks for having us hahahaha that was
fun I mean that's a memorable it was and
I'm fine yeah you sore everything's fine
let's move on okay you guys um a lots
happened yeah okay since we've been here
since I've been there the last number
one ela beautiful baby huh your body
bounce look at that body bounce right
back on I know
yeah that weird that I look at your
wife's body and sit down for a moment
oh yeah but I don't mind you okay what
yeah I'm okay with that because there
was nothing sexual behind but now ah
yeah but if I want if I want like this
if I want like this but your body yeah
oh what a creep
don't you guys see that's been
appropriate especially when you think of
childbirth are there men that get off on
the unnatural labor yeah as her labor
porn I've heard so I've not heard of men
but I've heard of women that orgasms
what huh which I'm doing
I like labor porn when they're working
that kind of labor
yeah yeah but not know I don't we did
have a baby yeah yeah we've been we have
been blessed got it the good almighty
has blessed us with a beautiful boy
child he is a handsome devil used four
months old and a great little fella yeah
we look at the photos and we always know
like we always turned to each other
beautiful because the last time I was
here I don't think you were even
pregnant I don't think yeah but you have
you guys hadn't done we were having sex
okay in preparation yeah yeah now are we
close enough for us to observe your
lovemaking Oh
if kalila I just took notes I don't
think you don't know I'm gonna do that
voyeuristic stuff what are you saying
you know your mute no you want to take
notes it's alright listen I know how
we're Asian we have own way of doing it
why do you spider monkey style
yeah well sneak up behind you know I
mean right oh no no no that's a crazy
top nicob are no no but you know she's
sleeping right do knock that well how
everyone is a behind torture kill noise
i rapidly hit it like a thousand times I
did see it you know you said somewhere
that it's hard to be your girlfriend is
that what you were talking about yeah
wow that's that's charitable what it
might harm me the bumps that me pumps do
you have eleven exactly but when I will
you mean when I stick it in pumps it's
just cuz he tires really quickly yeah
but they're long strong they're not but
you don't know what yes I do my stroke
no that's wrong I have eleven pumps with
the strokes are super long no well no I
mean no I don't say no your luhan's rude
okay
a long stroke of yellow I said it but
scientifically doesn't it is okay okay
I'm just because you're right if I did a
long stroke since it's not a long dick
yeah still I would have to be really
slow for Qi long as what you're saying
no I don't know we're not you know don't
put words the engineer yeah you're right
I'm putting yeah I apologize right guy
you know that you guys not a bright guy
rise by low and so Bobby bought that at
Zumiez it's a beanie
are you says yeah because I
I was in Hawaii so sometimes I act so
nice thank you oh yeah you're doing a
good damn movie in Hawaii for thriller
magnum p.i is TV show and I was like I
got my hair and I hadn't brought one
beanie and I walked into Izumi's in a
mall yeah and I go I need to be that
exact like really crazy and then they
guy you go well here's a selection I go
I went right to this there's like four
colors of this brand I like this brand I
didn't know was yours
issues like oh did they give that to you
good no I bought it because I really
know that that's my dream that when
someone picks something that's Teddy
fresh and they don't even know that it's
ours
oh yeah that was cool because I can but
you could tell that it was made by
people that are really it's kind of cute
they primo get beanies right cuz it fits
are you being anywhere yes you wouldn't
I we're all yes because like me Neela
okay we crafted we we were in the
laboratory perfecting that beanie for
years before he sit when we first made
Teddy fresh people are like weird the
beating where's the beating where the
because I'm a beanie connoisseur we said
wait hey
it's cuz everyone makes it to tired
mmm-hmm all right dude tired too small
it's like goalie
it's like goddamn the porch yeah you
know what it loosens mm-hmm it's not
like the vagina no I'm not a doctor I
know and then we were out there but the
vagina I'm sorry how do you it comes
back it's it goes back into its original
form but beanies other times or like
that these digits are just open oh yeah
yeah yeah can I say I by the way I want
to say they do go back to the original
form I can say that your video the
vagina I guess want to say for the
record yes because I mean we have had
coitus
we've affair since baby I was curious
does it feel the same yes it does same
it feel the same for you
I think so ya know at first I could tell
that like the things it it's like well I
had stitches
so there's kind of like a door tour dear
friend I know he would in well he's just
a big baby with big [ __ ] oh you
didn't do the what's an incision when
they do that little cut thing they're
gonna do it but then they're like well
he's so close and when they pulled out
his shoulders had just tore that thing
wide open
you would that you twirl your vag yeah
and then they went in there and they'd
be surgically yeah and she was like door
it's just one there and then she was
stitching me for an hour
yeah did not sound like wanna
complicated shape we know what the shape
is so you know but Michael did tear
between your [ __ ] or on the north
side oh it's the top side he doesn't
know where oh it's everywhere
multiple Bobby you and your your taint
tour yes well what else would tear
upwards well when they pull yeah yeah
yeah right it wouldn't make I've never
seen a vagina
that's what I'd hear at all yeah yeah
developed away what was yet what the
Joker's mom's vagina look like it's
really long and red why didn't the
Joker's vagina mom like like like yeah
you think his mom's vagina having a
stroke right now because I feel like
everything I think you may have got
brain brought your set you guys are like
I got am I having a stroke
yeah yeah you know usually when you get
in an accident unlike on a set they take
a 20-minute break right and they go
unbreakable by your own doing the show
man I would have loved a rehearsal
runner Wow he's a show because I've
never driven that whatever that [ __ ]
thing the GATS how was the Gatsby Dan
can we get a health report it's terminal
oh it means that we should pretty busted
return it it might be
I was dating Bobby this well in the past
week I've got he I thought he's had like
at least three strokes but we can't know
for sure that one more morning when I
woke she woke me up
what the [ __ ] happened there that's
where I forget yeah you can say I think
he well this is this is what I think I
think he's had a recent death in the
family and I think he's going through my
dad died very a dad died yes he's going
through a very like manic episode or
manic period and he I don't know I think
that's he's getting he widow mania comes
weird behavior is that true Bobby you
think Mike is given a damn we I don't
want that guy that guy with the brown
long hair get him away not that guy man
oh my god he's so sexy that hair
somebody with the mic can I ask you guys
what were you talking about your
behavior and your strokes yeah oh yeah
so the other day she woke me up abruptly
Mike yeah we go ahead if you ignored and
[Laughter]
you shouldn't be a like a dentist
technician something like not smooth
about how you thank you Dad all right we
got things Dan but a good guy just does
anything ring true about what color
other day I woke up and I was she here's
what it is she's from like the islands
she's from tropical areas yes so like I
don't know what it is but late at night
she just wants the room to be as cold as
Antarctica okay I wouldn't make sense if
I'm very cold intolerant but I think
that 75 degrees is a fair temperature to
sleep
oh yeah and right yeah exactly
72 is for me is quite cold me too yeah I
think seven is too cold 275 is a
five is fine yeah it is yeah but okay
but I do 75 she brings it down to seven
anyway my point is this okay yeah right
okay
so we're these complainants and then she
woke me up abruptly this is what
happened yeah so I stood up he was so
cold in the room what happened I
couldn't [ __ ] I couldn't move I froze I
had a thermic the thermic reaction utter
a word yeah I was standing there like
this right like with my underwear like
this and I was going you're you're being
funny about it which is which is nice
but I know as audience member this too
is like when I say when I'm talking
about a real story and I stand up and I
reenact it people laugh oh that's funny
it's not just my body's [ __ ] up
no you because the way I'm doing is
[ __ ] up cuz I'm a fat yellow guy right
but is that what it is no no your butt
was it Ashley
he's an untrustworthy narrator okay well
construction was coming into the house
that day and we have six animals so I
needed to put them away mm-hmm he's a
seventh animals I need I need him shut
away in a room while construction comes
and does their jobs so all I needed him
to do was get from one bed to the guest
room through all the animals in there
shudder he didn't do that he got up his
body froze and he couldn't utter a word
so immediately I was like oh my god he's
having history you were right so I did I
was a Keanu State you know I made him
say my name I checked for like symmetry
in his speech I did everything I had my
phone in my hand because it was the
weirdest thing and it turns out it might
have just been cold for him it wasn't
cold are you doing it was were you doing
a gag what do you what do you remember
I don't do gags in the morning like that
are you crazy what what do you remember
from it I remember going I had to go to
the hospital I didn't want to die
hypothesis I have is that he takes a lot
of unisom because it makes all he takes
a lot of unisom like it's like a sleep
aid take the next test because when he
jerked off at night he
it magnifies his orgasm so I think it
causes confusion when he's woken up
abruptly way hold on
back back back the gas be a friend okay
let me see something
okay you don't have to reveal everything
it's over the counter sleep aids called
unisom is a very small percentage of
people who take it wear it very tiny
percentage but him and his brother are
part of that percentage and apparently
it just makes you peek a little bit
harder okay so when I get a song you
spell that for me you and I you and som
it's not good for you at all when I
can't wait to take a little excess it
makes you horny or sleepy and horny
makes you [ __ ]
sleepy but it also makes you my brother
and I and I've looked it up on the
Internet
it makes us ten times more hornier than
normally we would be but do you get
sleepy also well yeah but here I think
only or I think a race against the clock
no because that the horniness lasts for
like a couple hours so who discovered
this you or your brother and you told
your brother yeah and he cuz like
mothers I can't years ago I'm like and I
said if you take an extra extra one
you're gonna extra tingly feeling yes
and my brother goes really bum I go yeah
he goes okay I'll try it and they're
like a month later you know I forgot
about it and then you brought it up I
told you but what the problem is now is
is that you're waking up in your camera
or I can't I can't get hard without it
so you just [ __ ] yourself okay baby
don't get it right so so does it make
your penis more sensitive or is a
heightened your orgasms orgasm
heightened saw orgasm and so when you
have a normal orgasm like no no if I if
I go and jerk off it's like oh okay I'm
done yeah so tell me about what does
this do it's it's like what you're
getting you gotta hit the day
[Laughter]
it sounds like you know like a morning
show with kids so you got to dig in a
certain what angle and wait your other
sensitive spots in the day
everyone knows yes right right yeah but
if you could hit it right with the
unisom feeling right you can you your
orgasms are like you're being dropped
you know that one ride at if you go to
like a street fair or whatever it drops
you all the way down mmm
guardians of the galaxy right like an
elevator ride or anything right it's it
feels like that with g-force yeah chief
work when you're doing or got that
powerful this is what happens you go I
actually have the end stage of when
someone dies from tennis when they
basically go into like this tightening
rigor mortis kind of like spinal art
that's what he does I get like I get
like you know how Emily Rose was on the
floor when she became possessed by the
devil and her boyfriend looks over and
she's in this like weird and so what is
the specific way like where is it that
you touch it then they give a pad pencil
well yeah it's can someone bring in a
pencil and pen do you do I hit the deck
no do you take can you draw it it's too
fresh for the YouTube weather you
we won't drive but is it a certain like
technique they use my finger then yes
thank you yes you can use your finger
I prefer that I don't take I don't even
drink coffee
why are you made of this yeah I don't
marry but I'm very I don't take a lot of
okay so alright so like let's say this
is my penis I'm just all right right
Zack you have soundbites and say oh yeah
yeah yeah so right here right where the
head is yes and with a stick stick part
it what do you call it that's the shaft
my bad my bad are we talking about the
front of the shaft or the back of the
ship so that's why I say so if it's
facing this way right so when I surf I
facing you and this is my dick right
I just what is the font the back head
part is my is what I'm looking at so the
back has that point part that goes up
like that right yeah so that's the part
but the orgasm is good but the thing is
is that um it's not healthy and I've
been uh the last three weeks because my
dad died and ever since then I've been a
little lost
actually I'm huh I've been a really lost
like I don't even know cuz I didn't cry
mmm so he died and I was in the room
with my brother and my mom when he
passed you were yeah yeah my mom and my
brother were so [ __ ] hysterical
mm-hmm like they acted like it was like
a black funeral I raised this but like
my experience actually what what do you
mean dad's sister came into the room
while he was still laying there like
that
in the hospital she came in and like we
were already there my mom and my
siblings entered me and we weren't like
panicking because we already knew that
it was coming it was like a tough week
so when it happened we were all kind of
dare not like panicking you know and
then she came and it was like like one
of those Turkish movies I don't know if
that makes sense like she started like
yelling and
yeah yeah crazy Wow and then I kind of
felt weird like am I supposed to react
that way yeah there was this we talked
to this guy like two weeks ago and he
said something really I think important
he's like when someone takes up too much
space in a room automatically we take a
step back and I think the same applies
with grieving and crying when you see
other people you know take their space
and grieve in such a big way it takes
away your you know all of your feelings
to do the same yeah it's like this when
I'm at dinner with a bunch of comics and
then like someone like Chris D'Elia or
Bryan Callen these alpha-male type of
characters they're gonna be the only one
maybe two at a table so I know that I
had to take a step back for bigger
personalities or the people that need it
right so it's the same [ __ ] thing you
know so but what I'm hearing is you are
you you're feeling a sense of guilt for
not having maybe mourned that the you
know you feel was the appropriate time
no so what what is it it's not all
there's you about the fight because it's
not what I imagined it would all be it's
it's not it's you know it's one of those
things your whole life you think about
sometimes even as a kid even I hated my
dad as a kid mm-hmm I [ __ ] hated him
but still I would lay in bed at nights
and I would imagine my dad dying or
something bad happening to him even
though that he wasn't the best [ __ ]
dad
it would break me right I couldn't even
think about it cuz it would make me sad
I love my family I love my parents um so
I didn't when it happened it wasn't
anything the way I thought it was gonna
be mm-hmm
well let me ask you this was was it a
gradual thing or was it a sudden illness
it was gradual over ten years over ten
years yeah but it's so funny that's what
it was was those years of us thinking
it's gonna happen at any moment I think
I prepared myself I think that's what it
is because when he did die I was like I
was just I was more relieved I think
it's a it's a
it's a feeling that I'm ashamed that I
had I know but I had it and I and there
was a part of me I went on thank God
he's like not struggling or suffering I
just kind of recently talked I just
started seeing a therapist and I just
talked about how I felt guilty for
feeling relieved when it happened
yeah did you ever cry no have you cried
yet over it yet or no I did I cried in
different ways at different times but
it's kind of like you describe it's like
it's not what you think it would be like
it's like all this when I'm gonna grow
up I'm gonna be this or you know you
have these thoughts as a kid like when
someone's gonna die it's gonna crush me
and then it's not really like that
yeah and I think the same happened for
me when my dad passed was you know
because it was gradual I felt that same
all of those that same really fun it
took me a long time to really cry but I
didn't put a label on it I didn't try to
make sense of the lack of Tears either
but if you if I look at pictures now it
hits me hard and I actually I'm able to
cry but that's what 15 years after the
fact
yeah I'm more sensitive about it now
than I was when I was 20 years old yeah
my friend Mike I was talking to him last
night he was like he's a comic and he
was like my dad died when I was 19 he's
like 40 or five now because this is not
a single day that goes by that were I
haven't thought about him so it's like I
just I just never thought this is like
the first you know grown-up thing that's
really kind of happened to me I think
like a week because I you know you know
as a comic you know I fought on people's
faces I mean I pee on you mm-hmm I mean
III act inappropriately I go crazy you
know I'm not real but I am you know
that's just me and you know when I'm
performing or whatever but like when it
boils down to it I I love my family and
I love where I come from and you just
don't you don't forget you know you
don't forget those moments it still
happens to me now like if I talk with my
mom
and she will start crying I don't cry
right now and it doesn't make me feel
weird sometimes that's weird
are you the oldest I'm the youngest
you're the youngest because some people
were like you're the oldest so that's
why your act I don't know I was like I
don't know well I don't know but my
brother and my mom went crazy and but
then my [ __ ] uncle so my dad has one
brother his closest brother did stood
walks up dude he drove all the way from
San Diego to Phoenix he walks in my
dad's laying there and you know how
Korean dudes love the Asian dudes like
to put the hand behind her back like
this mm-hmm he walks he walks in looks
at my dad and he goes oh he gets back in
the car and drives back to San Diego
okay that almost broke me what about
that almost broke you I'm just curious
yeah because you know my uncle isn't a
man to feel or express emotions I've
never seen either my dad or my uncle
Cryer and I thought right so that was
his way of like grieving but just that
gesture alone just the thought of it
made me really sad yeah and even sing it
now I'm gonna get me my [ __ ] man
there's no way boy oh boy grow grow grow
up
anyway I'll really get to be here thanks
for having me here I think when I first
of all unlike all of you guys I've never
had an immediate family member passed
still no never but the big things that
have happened to me in my life like I
for example I mean it's a completely
different experience but like in college
I had like an anxiety disorder that was
so bad that out that I was entertaining
the idea of suicide let's say and that
was probably at this point you know 15
years ago but that but a bit big things
take a long time to process and yeah you
know when it's too close to you you just
can't see
you can't see the you can't see the
trees from the forest as they say is
that what they said yes it is but
another thing though that happens when
someone like that passes someone close
to you is these broader themes of like
philosophical themes that you had like
what is life is it meaning it just felt
also meaningless right
whereas before because of my 12-step you
know I'm experienced and all the stuff
that I've learned you know of being
spiritual about it you know and living
in the moment and all those [ __ ]
things that they teach you right it's a
get all that [ __ ] went out the window
and I was just like we're like wow life
is meaningless it doesn't make any sense
none of it and I don't know if there's a
god but isn't there a comfort in that
though how meaningless and random and
you know like I don't believe and you
know any type of like destiny or I like
the spontaneous or random nature of life
and I for me it feels comforting to know
that I don't have to find a whole lot of
meaning into it I just have to find a
happy moments along the way feel it
wholly and then move on and it's my date
time to go it's time ago that's
comforting to me to expect that there's
something there beyond it brings me a
lot of anxiety that's a big expectation
but what's not comforting is the idea
that I'll never ever see him again
that's not comforting right yeah I
noticed where he influenced me as a
person like in my character and I see
that as the way that is that's what was
left yeah for the good or the bad stuff
that I see in myself that were like
moved on to me he's pretty you know
characteristics and yeah it's a blame
whatever I was can I say something no
it's funny that you say that and I and
when you were talking I was kind of like
I don't really know a lot of good
character is she every that he had he
really was a man of really simple no
words I don't know I don't know how he
feel
about politics I don't know how he feels
about food mm-hmm worry what he likes
what he doesn't like clothing he wore
like these blue light blue Smurf colored
coughing pants all his life
shame pants yeah no he just look like
Papa Smurf
it's just that he doesn't he doesn't
know what he looks like he doesn't give
a [ __ ] right and so um I don't know him
that's the thing I don't know I don't
know my dad and all I know anything
about him and that's what saddens me too
because when he died I was like oh [ __ ]
because he didn't have the the tools in
his toolbox to express any specific
thing because of the language barrier he
also didn't have why did you why did you
hate him when you were young I did to my
dad a lot so that's yeah I mean it you
know he was my dad was an alcoholic and
he was also violent and used to like
just my mom I mean I remember my mom
opening her mouth and teeth being
knocked out I mean he was a nightmare
and I used to pray anything really
believe in God but I used to go God
please kill this [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
hey guys I'm so sorry to interrupt we
got to go to break
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's just a couple minutes but nothing
though the bathroom guys we'll be right
back I'm gonna pick this up when we come
right back
[Laughter]
okay here's the deal you care about
having a clean mouth as we all do but a
normal toothbrush just doesn't cut it
any more it's almost the year 2020
that's the future and when the future is
here 2020
you better be using a futuristic
toothbrush and not that BS cup of
plastic piece of plastic couple bristles
it's not enough we need equip electric
toothbrush let me tell you about quick
starts at just $25 and here's what it
does for you in two pulsates doctors
dentists know that pulsating toothbrush
should give a better clean boom what
else do they do they have soft rubbery
bristles that will never damage your
teeth so it pulsates and then it
pulsates it kind of vibrates to let you
know when it's time to switch quadrants
so it get you get that perfect dentist
recommended is it a two or three-minute
brochure man two minute brush that's the
power of quip and it just twenty-five
does you're gonna find a better deal
anywhere on this planet you got a
beautiful kissable breath you're gonna
look forward to brushing that's the
sleek intuitive design that I love of
quip but more than anything I love the
clean baby quip starts is just twenty
five dollars and you get your first
refill pack for free at get quick calm
slash h3 it's a simple way to keep your
mouth clean to enjoy brushing and to
support the show it's GE t qu IP comm /
h3 get your first refill pack for free
let me say that one more time right now
GE tqu yp.com / h3 guys thank you to
quit
if you believe you're not being snooped
on or that nobody cares about your
online data well I'm sorry to disappoint
you
but you're wrong because you listened to
my show you're clearly smart and I have
to laugh whenever I read that you're
clearly smart enough to understand that
your privacy is under attack
hackers government's ad companies and
ISPs are all gobbling up your data like
all of it that's why I recommend getting
the software that I trust to protect my
online activity the most
expressvpn because you couldn't
understand that I said that it's
important to the sponsor that you
understand when I say their name so
expressvpn their app uses powerful
encryption to secure your data
expressvpn runs in the background of
your computer phone and then you use it
but on this and then you use the
internet like you would normally would
you download the app put the connect and
voila I don't know that voise are worth
it if I metal guy you download the app
clips in there click to connect and
Bob's your uncle
your protector I personally never go
online without expressvpn and you
shouldn't either Express B VPN is the
fastest VPN I've tried it costs less
than $7 per month and it comes with a
money day 30-day money-back guarantee
expressvpn uses new cutting-edge
technology called trusted server to make
sure there's no logs of what you do
online hentai fans take note it's time
to stop hackers Big Brother and Internet
companies from grabbing all your data
take back your on my privacy with
expressvpn guys you bet you if you're
not using if you're not if you're using
the internet without expressvpn that's
like having a one-night stand with a
girl that's been all the way around town
and back without a condom and I'm just
being honest it's that serious
it is like that EULA protect your online
activity
to date and by now hiking at three
months free at expressvpn calm /h three
that's expr e SS VPN dot-com /h three
for three months for free with a
one-year package visit expressvpn comm
/h Street will learn more
whew oh yeah but actually when I sign
you're like all the best and I just love
all your step and Dan inspirational
you're back
oh we are back we are back I have to I
have to I was telling Dan to say go to
break okay because I thought it would be
funny the way you were left but I just
died so I don't I didn't want Dan to
have to take the heat on that know what
I'm telling on breaking go to break yeah
that was um the timing of it though was
like because I was about to cry like if
you waited like what a [ __ ] Dan the
way but it was him because I was saying
it for a while I was like saying I was
saying say it say it say he chose the
exact moment to say I understand that
and I as soon as I walked in here to
that guy gave me real [ __ ] vibes like
Japanese internment camp okay
Wow Dan yeah Dan Dan gave me like you
know shut your mouth eat the sandwich
and your lawyer will be here next week
so anyway I expect an apology you will
have a formal written apology from Dan
okay you guys I'm sorry I'm sorry that I
actually I was listening to hila talking
about her experience with losing her
father actually was something I was very
close to but obviously not happening to
me ela is from Israel as you may or may
not know and heard I mean I don't you
know never stay don't ever talk like
that for years and so I wasn't I wasn't
in Israel with her at the time when her
dad heard her dad died of lung cancer he
was a smoker and he had a he died of
lung cancer you know and and I don't
know what your dad passed of a stroke oh
here well no what happened was he had a
bunch of strokes like 20 of them and
then he been over the years and then he
just then he had complications of it
Parkinson's and other things that have
eventually died from pneumonia pneumonia
it's just one of the complications yeah
because he was already I'm bedridden
right yeah
there's no way for him to sort of expel
all that mucus and it becomes a whole
big like infection sorry I don't know I
just let the Mona seem something like so
no cuz mom but it's not at the end it
does compromise you know is what my mom
way my mom my mom died my dad died my
mom screamed at me as she goes Nick
Faldo
really it was weird I wanted you to take
a photo not just one of his of his
departed take just you know document
what's going on right so I so she made
me do the selfie I did this I just
listened I did the selfie thing with the
timer with his what your dearly departed
far away [ __ ] it's a far away shot the
family forever
did you ever have the inclination to
smile just cuz it was a cuz cuz it's a
photo do you know what I mean no you
know why didn't smile because it
would've been funnier with the way we
did it and the way we did it was the
best way today and he had sunglasses
what you do know I didn't wear the
sunglasses you had him on I still have a
photo one of them I did wear gloves yeah
yeah well whatever I was respectful I
didn't wear on me so what was the funny
what you said you just being completely
still staring blankly into the camera it
was the best shot I thought the weird
what I found interesting was that as
soon as his dad died I got a barrage of
text messages and when I checked my
phone it's about 80 to 100 different
angles of his dead but that's exactly
what I needed
if I don't say it because then everyone
on the lines gonna be like it's a COPI
maybe it was a coping thing video of it
I really wish that people will prepare
you for death don't you think so like
there is no preparation you don't know
what to do I thought it was weird that
we were even standing in the room with
his dead body
it's we were standing for
can our and his family members came and
then people were hanging out there
talking thanks to his dead it's weird
yeah that's really sir my brother is it
this is head right and I go he has you
to kisses yeah because he did it like
five times well what does he what does
he care if you kiss everyone like
everyone takes it so differently and
then they expect you to do what they do
then in the middle of the hysteria
they're now playing hot potato with his
ashes potato with his ashes no one wants
dashes they got him cremated and now his
mom you know call to us to called me two
weeks ago and she's like I'm flying to
LA I'm like why she doesn't get me a
ticket because I'm picking up the ashes
and I don't want to spend the night with
the ashes of bringing the ashes to LA
and we're just two boxes of my dad's
ashes wait can you I don't understand
the the the logistics he he passed in
Phoenix and was cremated
yes your mom is flying your mom lives in
Phoenix she's flying to LA with the
ashes right because she doesn't want to
spend a single yeah we're at he's dead
we're at the place the guy goes who do
you want to do and I go who's the
options I've never done this before and
they go we could do you know service and
what the whole thing tell me how much
lot cause all that thing and I go what
about the thing where they just you know
bring him out right when he crying what
out he said whatever they do they burn
it out
the body will do that so I went about
the Box two boxes we split it in half my
brother and I I wanted the bottom half
interesting you got a specific part I
asked in the bottom I have because I
just feel like it's if you have the
upper half there's more likely of ghosts
wait I didn't even know you're [ __ ]
with me and I really believe that no no
you can you can decide which part of the
body they said no they said no
there's no like a wooden I don't want
also any other ashes in the ashes right
I went all my dad I don't want 3% of the
nine year old black guy that was the
janitor at school right I went all
Korean because Korean my dad's you don't
know who was incinerated before you you
don't want to bring in someone into your
home that you're unfamiliar because
that's when the haunting released yeah
that's that's right baby the whole thing
is so weird to me and it's really it's
like a lot more uncommon I guess it's my
people bury you that's the that's it I
thought they don't grind you out what's
the word work that you I grant you out
is not the right way thanks ash now why
me treatment cremate Ron Jewett all of a
sudden grind you out sounds more
official yeah don't cut to a commercial
Mel don't let me get it all right that
guy dad you know what guys you know I
figured you know I would I did shows in
Portland right after my dad died I went
to Hawaii got some that show and then um
things life goes on we move on and you
know
kalila and I we bought a new house you
did yeah and we live near you're near
you guys what's do you see that's close
that's closer Oh congratulations
and um the dog he's got a yard mm-hmm
god bless them have three dogs and three
cats do your dogs feel like second-class
citizens since you had a baby no way if
they always say that you know people
told me that and I was like BS my dogs
my little angels I think we really do
spend a lot of times with them which I
don't know if I hope people do that but
sometimes we actually get worried like
yes so they you said you don't think
he's paying enough time with your doing
because it's like you have so much to
juggle now but we treat them like I
can't the truth is that I try to it's
[ __ ] up because well first of all a
newborn baby Brooke just requires a lot
of attention so it's inevitable that
your dogs are going to be more neglected
more too
but not second-class citizens by any
means I'm very conscious about spending
time with them and to and even to say
that we got another dog we adopted
another dog so that our our first dog
had a friend and they get together great
and I'm happy to say that that has been
a smash success great but I love I love
them they're worried about when we talk
about having children is my fear that I
will love my dogs am my dogs are in life
I don't want to not be me and we did
hear that from other people that felt
like after the kid they didn't feel this
animal you know what I think about those
people I think good thing they never had
that strong relation but I think it's
possible but like for us it wasn't like
that at all
what can I tell you about having a son I
think the best way to learn about the
relationship with your own dad or with
your parents is you know by having a
child because you're almost reliving
your ear
esque that that's as close as you can
ever get to know your parent right what
they've been through and the thoughts
and the struggles and from the very
first moment of having this little
critter you know this little creature
you're not gonna give this really get
one I know you tried are you trying
but you don't want it I do but you try
to convince me I know you're trying I
appreciate it but I'm gonna say or
something right now no no thank you
thank you why I wasn't sure if it
sounded like you were yeah I thought you
guys were just talking about if we had
okay he does
you want kids he's very keen on them
I've never I've never really been I just
don't I feel like I'd [ __ ] it up royally
I feel like we'd [ __ ] it up
no man um I would explode inside her and
create life oh I wanted to go back i
when you take it when you take those I
wrote the name down you know unit zone
do you guys ever have sex on unison we
used to but she doesn't want to do it
it's weird I don't like I yeah I don't
like the the finality of it all and I
don't like this word because I I don't I
don't like the way his body stiffens at
the end you get rigor mortis when you
come yeah like his spine is gonna just
smack crazy can I say something right
now so you do you prefer to jerk off on
unisom than have sex that's his nightly
ritual it sounds like it yes definitely
yes you know can we go back to my dad
there's a circle have a lot of problems
yeah I have a lot of sexual problems mhm
and it's not fair to kalila and I'm
doing I'm getting numbers I'm trying to
figure it out okay what does that mean
yeah can we talk because what I'm trying
to do is I've got my numbers from
therapists I'm gonna go in and I'm going
to try to work on this problem I have
but yeah okay I have sexual problems we
have to understand though okay is is
that you know I lived through a lot yeah
okay and I'm not saying nothing that's
like there are kids that had were way
worse probably most people and I'm
making excuses but um I don't want to
get I want to be better for you baby
yeah receptive
yeah but any but anyway back to your dad
my no back let's go back to the baby
important thing you want the porn thing
go ahead the baby the baby you want the
baby you don't want the baby no I don't
want the baby is that a conflict that
seems like a big cost a big conflict
she's a woman because she she doesn't
think that I have the genes you know
mean that no well you think you don't
think that I have anything in my DNA
that's gonna be an asset to I think that
he is very special DNA but with very
special DNA comes the other side of that
coin which is psychopathy
he has violence in his family my family
I put murderers in my family heavy drug
use same for him but you know that that
all has to do
with upbringing yeah like but lucky
Bobby said his dad was abusive that's
how you end up with really what these
kinds of individuals who are
dysfunctional in society but you guys
have how many Pat's five six six yeah
how are they do you understand that Matt
you have that really good you have there
you go you're already a parent that's I
knew that I wanted to have kids listen
I'm not relying don't yell at her I knew
when we first got our first dog shredder
that means he'll I had this we had this
parental love and affection and we
raised him and we every the whole world
revolved we had so much parental love to
give I saw that and it wasn't just like
it was we had you have infinite parental
love to give he gets the love Alfredo
our new dog gets to love Theodore
he gets the love but what it was is that
you see that you have a nurturing
selfless side your kids not gonna grow
up in me a murderer just because
whatever you think you guys are
successful you are relatively
well-adjusted okay you've got means you
you've got love to give that's it you're
not as long as you okay okay serial
killers and all these weird
dysfunctional people a cephalic back to
like you'd ever know it's almost like
he'd take a gamble when you have a kid
but this stuff happens from Newark the
nurturing if you start thinking like
that everything is again
like walking on the street is a gamble
yeah you could get hit by a bus well you
know you said the key words to love yeah
he has a lot of love I just don't know
if it's in the parental sense like last
night say for instance our dog Julio had
explosive diarrhea I specifically said
don't give him the the the the pumpkin
treats because that'll give him diarrhea
he was like no it won't like he gave
Julio the pumpkin treats Julio had
explosive diarrhea around 5:00 a.m. I
think it's love
that's parental love but just a little
diary and we wanted to dog that pup to
enjoy to have to dampen a little defense
thing when Julio has diarrhea in our
bedroom oh yeah he doesn't know how to
do things quietly it turns into a
Broadway musical he did I'm asleep all
the lights have to be on and then he
acts as if I have forced him to be
Cinderella he's crying he's complaining
about the whole process of cleaning and
wiping I'll tell you what you get help
you get you guys are rich come on give
me a you get a night nurse you get in
any they help you I don't want to exempt
you from work you got a housekeeper and
then all the sudden yeah you're a great
parent you're capable there's a lot of
people that have kids thank you all
right so let me tell you but if you
still don't want to have a baby that's
fine but if you feel like you are not
gonna be a good parent I have no doubt
that you'll be good parents I agree
though the concern of that the very
concern of it is what proves that yes
did you already care Arden yes you know
who's a bad parent people who like you
know get pregnant in the bathroom in
McDonald's high on that and then there
the baby is just a burden to them that
they only did it's illegal for them to
kill literally and that's the only
reason they carry and that's the guy who
goes and kills people yeah but you know
every time you learn about serial killer
or all these [ __ ] up people or
deranged rape a horrible child Aaron's
are evil people yeah hunter yes you
watch that show and that's I'm also
thinking about that when I say that yeah
yeah
like a mom who humiliates yeah yeah you
like a sexual yeah yeah but the thing
that you do when we go like if I'm going
on vacation or I'm on the road we could
do something and the kind of preparation
you do for the dogs yeah getting them a
sitter I'm obsessive getting them all
the right things that they need so those
are all things that
I don't think that serial-killer parents
didn't do these are things that they
weren't there you were there you know
I'll be there too I think you know the
circular you know the serial killer
parent does they don't even say they're
leaving and they just close the door and
lock ish yeah or or Jeffrey Jeffrey why
do you have the bones you know I mean of
a dog it's like just underneath the you
know mean the porch yeah right and this
is going letting it go
okay Jeffrey don't do it again me my god
oh you going back to Korea you would say
if he found bones what happens there
you're gonna go to the mines I don't
mind you're gonna mind into you're all
that is out of your system right that's
how we do it we don't let them out in
society so what's that a stroke moment
yeah it was transient but it was a
stroke in I think why do you why are you
so hesitant I mean is it something about
the way is it Bobby it's mean to me yeah
mmm probably a 60 60 percent probably
Bobby 60 percent Bobby you don't think
that Bobby is capable of being a good
dad I think that he's capable of showing
a lot of love I just I have this fear
that it will feel like me being a single
mom in terms of the workload he's a good
provider he's a good financial provider
but in terms of just doing that you want
to yeah I really I want what if you have
a nanny even then I I think I would
resent him if I didn't see him change
but it's nothing but how do you feel but
are you gonna not change we don't know
we because we've never been there we've
never done it so we don't know what I'm
gonna be like what do you mean I've had
but you know we've never had a baby
together so we don't know what I'm gonna
be like when I see the baby what I feel
like it's gonna happen is like you know
I'm gonna pick the baby up and there'll
be a glow
that won't happen let me tell you what
happens romanticize there's no blow in
fact let me tell you this
Theodore just turned four months and I
just started to like him do you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah go be our
noggin we did I didn't like Kobe at
first do the puppy work no sleep [ __ ]
pissed
crying hours crying crying crying crying
but then all of a sudden I was starting
to imagine like crying noises when I was
in the shower I just started hearing all
the time but is crying but then what
happened he starts recognizing you and
starts preferring you he starts to love
you and then you walk into his vision
and smiling what's the grab you but
that's really the beginning you know not
helping me out one bit but you know but
you know okay if you don't think he's a
he's a good dad then I mean what's the
long-term plans here let's just be
honest to have you want more dogs you
sohbats Oh Bobby's your life partner yes
yes I hope yes when she is the baby this
is what we're gonna do the baby's born
when okay well with the baby's born what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna grab the baby
yeah I'm gonna stick it in front of you
have to do this in front of a piano
first moment he's born and then put it
back in I don't put it back at it he
doesn't I don't cook him back in there I
just want to see if that I won the
lottery I got one of those he's very
fascinated with very special human
beings yeah I don't know I I have a fear
that if our child becomes just so
painfully average and mediocre I wonder
what you guys are overthinking this Yano
overthinking not you know me I am I am
easing you you guys you guys know what
you're saying well hold on hold on
survivor do you guys do couples therapy
ever okay no we're gonna you should do
that and talk about the baby thing cuz
I'm gonna be honest with you you guys
have some lush
to work out here where the babies yeah
the babies they have so many things you
have I have a lot of things to work out
within my own self well you see a
therapist and then you guys need to see
a therapist oh yeah you're good 34 ok 34
thank you bye you guys need to work this
out because the baby thing seems
important to you and I'll be honest the
baby thing is important because when you
guys start to age out a little bit yeah
all of a sudden you yeah it's a
beautiful thing it's like when you have
a baby you realize that there it's a
goal a whole new stage of life that it's
like you're not going down that that
beautiful road it's in many ways I think
as a parent you think oh well this is
the point of life and I I know that's a
subjective experience because it's a
it's a new perspective of learning so
much about yourself and your forebears
and everyone around you and
understanding the world and a new
perspective that you had no access to
it's like seeing colors a new color for
the first time that you couldn't see
before it there's just there's a new
phase of existence that's meaningful and
powerful and important it's reproduction
baby that's why we're all here
no mm-hmm we do have friends who choose
not to have kids and that is totally
fine but I feel like if one of you
wanted you know or one of you not sure
then it's worth talking more about Lee
when I acquiesce to the idea and said
okay fine you know if this I'm not
opposed to post I just have fears I
understand yeah what's do this what's
the plan I'm just somebody who likes to
plan ahead I'm usually him so when it's
time to talk about it he's just not
someone who wants to talk about what the
process will entail and so he doesn't
quell my fears you know it's hard and I
have to tell you we didn't really want
to talk about it either we we barely
watched any preparation videos and we
didn't go to the closet and take any you
didn't do anything and luckily or
that we we just met Christina and Tom
around the time we got pregnant and
Christina throughout my pregnancy kept
text messaging me
you gotta get a doula you gotta get help
you gotta get help
you're gonna need a nurse and and I kept
ignoring it I was like yeah yeah sure
we'll get it when we get there we'll get
it then she was like no you gotta get in
now yeah I'm giving you the best
recommendation you got a call and I
didn't call her and like two weeks later
she'll text me did you call her yeah and
thank God they listened to her because
now we have help and we wouldn't our
life would be so bad right now if we
didn't have help yeah and we both work
and we want to work we both like being
productive and we're able to still work
and still be with him and still take
care of our dogs and you know it's a lot
to juggle so you do need to prepare for
it but doable ya can do it we also have
DD DD yeah that was one of my
stipulations my stipulation is I need it
so quiet we have a sound bite where she
says DD mega dude it's a family member
her name's Dee Dee she's childless but
she's the neighborhood nanny basically
and she's from the Philippines and we
just love her so much so it's like if
you bring DD here I'll have that child
I think Lyla takes care of like you
bought her a whole new set of teeth
I did buy DD had no teeth yeah the
party's just like perm like why would
you for DD I'm jealous of people with
fake teeth because it always looks
better than mine I know and then you
know what you don't my teeth what
happened I have no teeth you know that
right do you have 405 teeth you know
that right I don't think you know could
I show you know I don't have to I have
no teeth I just said Oh show me and I
show you but don't make one
me I wouldn't make funny okay so explain
at the inside look I'll explain to show
me first and then all like okay I was
out how about this I could have a friend
of the cameras picking it up they won't
so why don't I go over to you know
they'll just they won't show your camera
don't come too close to me I don't want
kid I don't want to see it very up close
okay come on up
oh really why he has to chew steak in
the front so so you're missing all of
your molar teeth
what happened I don't rush you don't
write you never brush I do no wait for
how long did you not breath forty years
I dunno applause yet Matt was you pre or
post brush one of the things that I we
talked about on the phone before we met
is I have really weird oral fixations or
I have really weird things about oral
hygiene well it seemed like 16 teeth so
I don't think that's weird so the good
part is that there aren't crevices let
me smell back there because it's just
gums huh when you guys when you guys
make out do you ever feel his gums I
don't go that far her tongue doesn't
travel and those I try not to travel
like Syria you know I just curious dude
now so they got yanked and you just said
forget about it do couples make no I let
time I did it I didn't go to a hospital
or dentists and go that question we made
out do couples make up like do just a
random make out not really I don't even
like all the hands to be on it really
and I just I hate it what she does you
know when she doesn't like we're
watching the movie today right in the
movie and she put her hand there so what
I do is I like so she crossed the hand
like this and I'm and in my head now I
go I don't pull back a little bit you
still think that you're pulling away
don't push in because that's trying too
hard you think about yeah
yeah in my mind yeah you too because
well I have Tourette syndrome and like
OCD so I'm very neurotic about like
touching event and so like I like being
affectionate I am very affectionate with
ela and so if we're walking sometimes
I'll grab her hand and I'll hold it and
I'm back that's nice and then literally
five seconds I'm over yeah you know it's
fun to do the gesture how far do you
think you and I could like maybe hold
hands you think in public and see how
far how far do you think you you know be
able to walk I mean if I'm consciously
making the effort I'll walk all the way
up to the I'll walk up to Canada with
you holding it okay however you and I
should you know you and I should do is
hold hands on Ventura Boulevard and go
pouring megawhatts holding hands see how
long we can walk okay I think what you
doing
let's see how long I think that's art I
think that performance art because you
other's dad like I have you ever even
tried a Mac I had on no I don't even
think I've seen one in the wild
he bought Maggie mints from Hawaii
magnets in Hawaii how's that for
bobblehead didn't bring good for the my
thank you have you burned a maggot yeah
I was it scary where were you I couldn't
even put it on yeah I had I saw that the
story of Hawaii yeah I almost put it on
it look it was just yeah I'm sure you
like it I don't know if you guys like
the guy but you know you're sure I like
it I don't know what you don't know how
you feel about know where you might like
oh I don't know you might like we're
young gay so you guys are you guys
having any money okay we did the photo
already and we want to bring him on
again I want to have loan
we want him on to to kind of just you
know I explained to us in layman's terms
what the heck's going great they are
brighter we're really low brown really
dumb we're very have more teas like I
told you earlier new points our topics
are very dick and death heavy but that's
about it
yes yeah death death dying dick and
death where that's our Forte we don't do
very well what the hell do you think we
talked about here I just say you at the
mint now you interrupted me because I
could
say dd- because I because I follow you
on social media yeah and so I'll I'll go
by and go killing it you want to see
whatever you want to see what I tweeted
go ahead and come I didn't want anything
to make you stop complimenting me you
guys are killing every and also wherever
I go people go oh h3 you know without
even they see just that that's all I do
[Laughter]
make sure to say that to congratulate
him for knowing me okay so I tweeted
this this morning and this was
controversial today is that
international lesbian day in case did
you know so I woke up this morning I saw
trending and I said wow what a
coincidence
I just celebrated hashtag international
lesbian Day last night before bed thank
cuz I jerk because I masturbated to
lesbian porn she said I got lots of hate
this is a really bad tweet dude also not
the day to do it
well literally it is literally the only
LGBTQ citizens are literally having the
rice debated right now by SCOTUS so it's
a bit of a rough day for us
this is a tired trope and it rings of
homophobia and it's straight-up unfunny
my guy wait homophobia I I thought that
was so far from it it might have not
been an obvious it's a stupid joke yeah
I mean am I not allowed to jerk off so
as the employment with did you guys talk
about with Andrew yang the whole
shangela's thing no it was he came
before shingles but would you guys like
to talk to bang Ginga you probably have
talked about to death we we a lot on our
you flip flop connect but I feel like
you have the same take as a stupid
quite a sink I've seen you your take
which is basically that it's just not
funny
right and that's the problem the in its
what andrew yang said was so punitive
listen orgasm right topic really just
kind of like it just irritates me
okay to the bone okay I'm not the guy
get squirmish okay thank you know I
don't really oh you had a really good
point of view about the guy should
here's the thing is is that for many
many years
all right even I went to high school in
the 80s and people would just walk up to
you and go what's up [ __ ] really right
eighties and they were like that would
be the principal like they would and
you're you're supposed to just haha and
then we would you would be like even in
that I did a commercial were director
called me a [ __ ] what when recently I
know I know the guy I'm a but was a
recent know many many years okay but you
eat us yeah right so you know people
used to say it and not get fired my
awful but you know what the guy said it
on a podcast three years ago and you saw
the podcast right it's like I've seen it
yeah he said yeah no I do so many
[ __ ] podcast I say all kinds of
[ __ ] you couldn't find anything
saying really say something right and so
it's like I would have not fired him I
would have give him a pass also my point
of view is is that it doesn't offend me
because I'm Korean you know coke you
don't do that you know so a [ __ ] is for
Chinese [ __ ] it's for more Korean and
they used it for the Vietnam War as well
the Vietnamese are I didn't even know
about this words yes what source you
know [ __ ] is a very fascinating word I
enjoy I use it many there's a got it
during my wings nicely yeah yeah could
it be K in the back well then I think do
Park Jung kook
yeah so so [ __ ] is this so [ __ ] started
in and kind of say this I think I made
this up see the etymology of the word
[ __ ] I think I might have made up but I
think I've said it so many times that
I'm going to just say that I okay
basically what it is is that during the
Korean War American soldiers he would
walk through a village and the villagers
would go villagers would go when they
saw an American soldier would they would
say me [ __ ] mm which means America or
American mm-hmm but it sounds like them
saying me [ __ ] mm that's what that's
gotta be right that's what it yeah I
think how in the Philippines all white
people are Joe yeah why cuz there was
this one commercial back in the 80s or
early 90s we're like I think it was a
good race car driver his name was like
Joe something that was the only that's
all so that's that those are only
reference for like a white man really
like an Italian last name like Romano or
something like they see a white guy like
Joe mano you know oh yeah Joe but also
the military thing the whole GI Joe
thing uh-huh yeah I think it's probably
the correct
fatum ology yeah so you've got so let's
just recap you got [ __ ] you've got [ __ ]
slope is the one is now RR o slope but
are the present unzipper all non but
wait I want to break this down watch
geographical location amis that's yeah
that's cruel that is cruel but you know
what they used to say that to us all the
time back in the day not you know so
funny I run into people like Ali Wong or
these young Asian if it's so easy you
know right well I I auditioned for this
you know movie with you know I guess
like white people back in the day the
only auditions we got were
you know you would walk to you go to an
audition and people would be dressed as
ninjas like full-on with that mask and
everything and that's what we would get
back in the day right Lamia so they you
know we saw racism even in Hollywood
differently than they these younger kids
let me let me ask you this because [ __ ]
the bit I guess another controversial
point was that it was the first Asian
SNL cast member going alongside what was
this Boeing Boeing yeah yeah not
familiar with this comedy he's at the
first in a second set oh he is Rob
Schneider
Rob Schneider was the first angel you
know okay okay good I brought a Filipino
is he really yeah he's half Filipino
he's the most full-blown Filipino Rob
Schneider is Filipino you didn't know
that I no idea you're [ __ ] with me
some Jew not even Jewish
so jo koy is one half Filipinos Wow
Rob's the second we have we have 10
minutes before where that sucks
wrap it up you're not can she not stay
longer because wait can she not stay a
little longer know what she have to pick
up her kid from school or some [ __ ]
but I want to say coming from that
background of feeling discrimination for
for asian-americans or hate whatever
Asians in Hollywood do you think that
that that guy being cast at the same
time as Shane was some in some way truck
more troubling for you know for me no
it's not for me it's it's a way of SNL
42 even a defense which is all right you
know he's a comic he said it three years
ago but listen we're hiring an agent
cast member yeah right he's a comic he
apologized we're not gonna fire him
do it again let's move on right but it's
like when you're when you say one thing
as a comic and it ruins your career it's
so stood for life it's it's so it's like
what's the [ __ ] point that's why I
like Andrew yang for it but he got a lot
of hate just a tional community for
saying hey we live in two we live in a
it's this too punitive everything can't
be this way and we should just you know
let him know that he's made a mistake
give him an opportunity to you know
correct that you know but not fire him
and totally just destroy his entire
career
you gotta rehearse right you're trying
to be funny
you gotta try stuff and yeah it works
and what doesn't work and if it doesn't
work maybe you're not that good too
right but what can you do you're trying
what have you said anything on this
podcast that you regret or that was a
little more like you're like I should
have said her yeah me did I've dropped
an bomb he's gotta edit Oh a lot
oh you edit them I didn't get to edit
yeah I don't edit them every episode yet
it's you said [ __ ]
you know like in [ __ ] in the same just
last episode you said [ __ ] oh yeah I
said [ __ ] in the first thing you say
that pretty I said it's hard in the
first like 10 seconds and I was like
okay guys no more cursing let's keep it
clean I know YouTube's cracking down and
the first thing I say what was the
context of the are bomb but I do know
what I say about the [ __ ] I says we
need a little grace period on the [ __ ]
yeah yeah you can't just take that away
from Eskimos want to be called Inuits
now for Eskimo right so what I'm saying
to you is I will call you in Ewan when
one day when I ever even meet one of it
Eskimo is derogatory they don't want it
because do you know what's the weirdest
one a little people isn't that so
derogatory hey little guy
a little guy would be a better option
what it offer up some I'm sorry from
happy what is the problem
well happy no I'm really I really don't
know well I hope grew up bad words but I
guess apparently uh it people probably
started to use it derogatory like you I
will go to Bob because he's a little
short me and say what's up [ __ ] yeah I
think but dwarf was never used in a
derogatory way Wharf is it's or I guess
right they're different the dwarf is a
medical term exactly they're different
the midgets and the dwarfs they don't
like each other why they're at war with
each other but have you seen well Oh
smarter because they're bigger heads
dwarves are smarter and then midgets
have magical powers yeah and then Val
Kilmer's all about the yeah also great
in island of dr. Moreau effect at the
end they people need to just recognize
when someone is trying to be funny yeah
and I at least remember that that was
the intention so like if I'm gonna paint
until I'm gonna paint like Leonardo
DiCaprio I can't paint you know Leonardo
- I don't want that so I'm not gonna do
it let's let's just you know relax we'll
end we'll end it soon okay no it's not
fair it's not fair she could just leave
Theodore by himself for like an hour
great name Theodore we have ten minutes
I think
no but seriously how long do you think
he could survive by himself not a couple
hours easily your baby could survive
I've seen documentaries on at nine hours
by itself really look at the Oh about
that Japanese powerful yeah who just
receives orphans in the middle of the
night remember what people would just
leave babies at their doorstep
the [ __ ] magical neglected babies
[Laughter]
there was a couple we're gonna end in 10
minute now we're addicted to playing
video games and arcade Japanese they
left their baby didn't feed it for what
nine weeks it died right then they went
to trial right they were exonerated and
then the government they didn't had
another baby how are they exonerated
they just were because I think that they
were they labeled the addiction like
they made it a medical condition the
addictions right is that what it was
it's also I think about this way it does
a video games is such a huge industry
rights that they don't it's a shame
because that kid probably would have
grown up to be a hell of a gamer right a
champion I chant you would have been
their goal he would have been there the
protege if you and I had a baby bro be
good one he'd be a [ __ ] up looking
baby wait Jonah would carry the baby I
would you would run on one of my cheeks
am i right am i right I think this is
gonna sound strange but I kind of is a
fantasy of mine to see you carry baby oh
really why I feel like you would just
transform into everything that I've ever
wanted you to be yeah yeah yeah yeah
where would it come out though my
butthole no no I'm just saying if we're
not talking about like you know
logistics in that way it'd be kind of
cute to see you pregnant
youhad mother I think he would really
enjoy it oh but the cucumbers in the
eyes we go to the eyes I put the clay on
my face right
the baby's hibernating I'm just I know
we're closing soon which is so unfair it
makes me feel so sad that like we have
so much you're like you're really
rushing us you know it makes me feel
uncomfortable but it's fine next time
maybe you'll give us more time maybe on
we got to do this again yeah maybe more
ridiculous no I mean sure my mom where's
my mom
which one there she's in big she's
visiting I didn't know that we're
starting at 1:00 when I saw did you
purposely do this dude I'm literally
literally discussing keeping my baby
alone for the maximum time possible that
he won't die by honestly listen here's
what here's the deal I really like your
clothes a lot I don't want all of them
because I mean I understand you don't
you certainly not gonna won't use these
are the ones I'm gonna take we have more
by the way because of that shirt I just
saw maybe there's a shirt I'd like to
get from you not that shirt but you
maybe a brand new one in there no no I
buy a new one
yeah but we have a ton of [ __ ] let me
give you all of them we have like a full
website no but we're not I'm not but
what I'm I'm just trying to meditate no
as a final thought here well you guys
come back absolutely
you guys are you do touch your penis I'm
yeah I'm just curious
yeah I do that sometimes
I understand you know I listen Howard
Stern he says he's always touching his
penis during the show I have a thing
where I have to squeeze in my left
breast
I'm uncomfortable if I'm anxious I my
natural go-to is to just please my pack
or chest not in any is just a comforting
feeling
watch good turn I don't do that very
well try this is right here and it feels
good if you see difficult left yeah it's
like a diffuse it diffuses the feeling
in your child exactly a release
just regular black dancing whatever you
want just because of the Gaspee I just
need you to sign any injury yeah you
honestly but let me ask you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you really
[ __ ] believe that even if I did get
her on that I would press charges okay
do you believe that your mind no I don't
but you know what would have what happen
what do you know what a prudent a
prudent man always gets the signature
yeah so you're not missing it yeah we
leave I want it I need to meditate on
something important yeah I'm trying to
imagine Bobby as a father right now I
think them there's a lot already have so
many pads deals already doing be my son
be my son right now call me I'll give
you the [ __ ] look Harold think you
know what I said I think Bobby is he's a
caustic crazy neurotic guy but he it's a
front he's a [ __ ] mania almost
poisonous oh yeah but I think but I
think it's just it's your hard exterior
because don't you are you're yearning
for for real for real 'no substance I
see it you the weather you're reacting
to I mean I I really think that it that
a child could really bring something
maybe that you don't even see in him yet
and if it backfires can I drop yes I'll
take it yeah but they only last for nine
hours so just make sure but I do think I
think I think you don't want to adopt
either that was my other option I don't
you know I don't want to rush into one
because if we get together with this in
the bag
well why do you want to adopt you don't
want to go through the pregnancy not I
want to see what my juice and your juice
together or easin our family anyway
really emotional I just want to say the
pregnancy itself wasn't that bad
and end the delivery to talk to us I'm
telling you you put in the [ __ ] yeah
that's great firesides all are you
afraid of dying from vaping because I'd
all the vaping crisis but lately as I've
been the counting how many times they do
it now how many times a day I've been
trying to do 50% of whatever you like a
cigarette now where he asked you will
he's not allowed to vape in front of our
animals it's a want you guys I need this
I need this to work out and this baby
issue this can't you guys need to you
guys need to get on the same page here
on this baby issue it's important to me
it's important to everybody listening
because your Tom's like that - it's a
girl you with with baby you know what
it's okay yeah it's funny you guys now
with the [ __ ] babies it's a [ __ ]
it it's a sales pitch I don't it's a
sale you want you what you're trying to
do it's like this dude it's like back in
the 60s if I got like drafted into
Vietnam right I saw all this blood and
guts and it came back into my small town
right with the backpack like in Rambo
first blood I'm warming back in the town
and you're my buddy from high school and
you're like hey Bob you got back from
Vietnam and I looked at us you should go
man
free drugs [ __ ] you're the best one and
then when you're out there right that's
what you're doing yeah it's not gonna be
good we're not having a baby really
great next time you guys come on here
one of you better at pregnant
well that's Bobby Lee and kalila I'm
afraid I don't know your last name
okay what is it yes okay fantastic tiger
belly you guys know about him you guys I
love you guys suck your belly I wanna
see this my document closed but for a
quick Bobby Lee live.com my document
closed get tickets see this man on tour
he's hilarious vanilla I've seen it he
crushes it every time I saw I saw you at
the comedy club you crushed it crush
did I love that I remember when you
recognized and then you go you come back
to me yeah so bad yeah oh my god
probably one of the best of that evening
everywhere dying how was that good a
lady had an award a lady
dude there's a girl from me who had an
abortion she was laughing all right what
were you doing that you wanted to stand
up is that why you're there I mean I
think I said that too no I wanna watch
my boy or somebody said I go I think
he's gonna start this for me what the
view no yeah you should we just can't
imagine though imagine that going on the
road doing stand-up and single your fans
we don't want it to her no I don't want
to that's not for me okay
but I would like to see you again I want
more time next time I would see you an
hour and a half but we did right you
know yeah we did yeah and and imagine
all the ground would cover to me you
crashed into the wall so we need you
back on Tyger Tyger belly right yeah and
I wanted to say this is gonna be a
relationship that's gonna be living on
forever so thinking wouldn't were even
in closer proximity and I feel like
spiritually as well yes I have a couple
of things I need a plug yeah oh yeah
yeah I did a second episode of magnum
p.i and I'm gonna do break - great
magnum p.i that comes out during the
Halloween it's a Halloween episode and
what network is that where you play yeah
I'm I am I am so excited magnum p.i I
can't wait to get a lot my first one
came out Friday is it the silver she she
hated the show don't say that don't say
that about you but he was great he was
great - hey no hold on one second every
joke I said no you got my truth wait
were you that where you just they like
comedy relief for you yeah yeah so well
no I have some but anyway um I would say
a funny line or whatever aiming dannis
screaming Ethan and the don't worry
about no but no but I want to hear the
story when hear the story no stop I
wonder the story
I was just outing Dan but he just tell
the story really what was I saying
Maggie I
anyway yes Halloween special yeah it
comes out I play Yoko Ono the Mexican
guy what's his name
Danny Hernandez he's the star he's
Pleasant Magnum what about Yoko I play
you're going on you in the in the
episode that's all sound accurate
anything else there you want to bug no
come on what are you upset no I love it
oh I did we did an hour and a half I
didn't want to [ __ ] up your plug no
there's no nothing to plug Magnum Magnum
yeah I go I want to watch it that's all
come see me on that come see me at the
shows doing shows Tiger belly taco bell
e Bobby Lee live if you seem on the road
got names switch lanes what kind of car
do you drive so people come watch off Oh
Prius thing done for thank god you're
pretty
we need to limit Bobby's horsepower to
10 we had a set designer Wow we don't
have a set this we want I want to make
cosines like it wasn't that expensive we
did this whole studio space for like 20
grand
wow that's great and there's a window
behind that the window to the freakin
main street there is yeah Oh found foam
oh wow sound formal any way by which way
more I love you and we'll see we'll see
you guys soon for sure okay Tata
[Music]